welcome to part two on the presentation
on
level one exponent rules so let's start
off by reviewing the rules we've learned
already
if i had
two
to the
tenth
times
two
to the fifth
we learned that
since we're multiplying exponents with
the same base
we can add the exponents so this equals
two to the fifteenth
we also learned that if it was
2 to the 10th
over 2 to the 5th
we would actually subtract the exponents
so this would be
2 to the 10 minus 5
which equals 2 to the fifth
at the end of the last presentation and
i probably shouldn't have introduced it
so fast i introduced a new concept what
happens if i have
2 to the 10th
to the 5th power
well let's think about what that means
when i raise something to the fifth
power
that's just like saying
2 to the 10th
times 2 to the 10th
times 2 to the 10th right all i did is i
took 2 to the 10th and i multiplied by
itself 5 times this was fifth power well
we know from this rule up here
that we can add these exponents because
they're all the same base
so if we add 10 plus 10 plus 10 plus 10
plus 10
what do we get
right we get 2 to the 50th power
so essentially what did we do here all
we did is we multiplied
times 5 to get 50. so that's our third
exponent rule is that when i raise an
exponent to a power and then i raise
that whole expression to another power i
can multiply those two exponents
so let me give you another example if i
said
to the
7 and all of that
to the negative 9
once again all i do is i multiply the 7
and the negative 9
and i get 3
to the
minus
63.
so as you see it works
just as easily with negative numbers
so now
i'm going to teach you
one final exponent property
if i have
let's say i have
times
say 9
and i raise that whole thing to the
100th power
it turns out that this is equal to
2 to the 100th power
times
9 to the 100th power
and let's make sure that that makes
sense let's use let's do it with a
smaller example what if it was
what if it was 4 times five
to the third power well that would just
be equal to
four times five
times four times five
times
four times 5 right
which is the same thing as 4 times 4
times 4 times 5 times 5
times 5 right i just switched the order
in which i'm multiplying which you can
do with multiplication
well 4 times 4 times 4 well that's just
equal to 4 to the third
and 5 times 5 times 5 is equal to 5 to
the third
hope hope that gives you a good
intuition of why this this property here
is true and actually when i had first
learned exponent rules i would always
forget the rules and i would always do
this proof myself or the other
proofs and a proof is just an
explanation of why the rule works
just to make sure that i was doing it
right
so given
everything that we've learned now
actually let me review all of all of the
rules again
if i have
two to the seventh
times two
to the third
well then i can add the exponents to the
10th
if i have 2 to the 7
over
2 to the third
well here i subtract the exponents and i
get 2 to the fourth
if i have 2 to the seventh
to the 3rd power
well here i multiply the exponents that
gives you 2 to the 21
and if i had
2 times 7
to the 3rd power
well that equals 2 to the third
times 7 to the third
now let's use all of these rules we've
learned to actually do
to actually try to do some what i would
call them composite problems that
involve you using multiple rules at the
same time and a good composite problem
was that problem that i had introduced
you to at the end of that last seminar
so if i said
let's say i have
squared
times
to the 8th power
and all of that i'm going to raise to
the negative 2 power
so what can i do here well 3 and 9 are
two separate bases
but
9 can actually be expressed as an
exponent of 3 right 9 is the same thing
as 3 squared so let's rewrite 9 like
that
say that's equivalent to 3 squared
times 9 is the same thing as 3 squared
to the 8th power
and then all of that to the negative 2
power right all i did is i replaced 9
with 3 squared because we know 3 times 3
is 9.
well now we can use the multiplication
rule on this to simplify it so this is
equal to 3 squared
times
3 to the
2 times 8 which is 16
and all of that to the negative 2.
now we can use the first rule we have
the same base so we can add the
exponents and we're multiplying them
so that equals 3 to the 18th power right
2 plus 16
and all of that to the negative 2.
and now we're almost done we can once
again use this multiplication rule and
we could say
3 this is equal to 3 to the 18 times
negative 2 so that's 3
to the minus
36.
so this problem might have seen
seemed pretty daunting at first but
there aren't that many rules and all you
have to do is keep seeing oh wow that
little part of the problem i can
simplify it and then you simplify it and
it'll you'll see that you can keep using
rules until you get to a much simpler
answer
and actually the level one problems
don't even involve problems this
difficult this will be more on the
exponent rules level two but i think at
this point you're ready to uh try the
problems
i'm kind of divided whether i want you
to memorize the rules because i think
it's better to
almost forget the rules and have to
prove it to yourself over and over again
to the point that you remember the rules
because if you just memorize the rules
later on in life when you haven't done
it for a couple years you might kind of
forget the rules and then you won't know
how to get back to the rules but it's up
to you
i just hope you do understand why these
rules work and as long as you practice
and you pay attention to the signs you
should have no problems with the level
one
exercises have fun